dude I'll tell you this they had when I
was um working in Charleston when I was
working in Charleston South Carolina
they had a smoothie outfit over there I
worked it and it was a bootleg kind of
health and wellness shop and it was
called frozen options was the name it
was like a startup smoothie deal
frozen options and self-tanning
eventually was but that came later but
so and they had a manager the guy was
just some guy who was basically trying
to hire people and then have set you
know trying to hook up with the lady you
know trying to hire cute chicks or even
busted chicks and get him to do a lot of
tanning until they looked attractive and
then make love to him you know I think
that was kind of some of his you know
business model because he was kind of
sad on the inside a little but anyway
yeah I worked that frozen options right
and uh I don't know why I thought of
this but so at one point we got the
tanning beds and they had a man that
came in one time an urban gentleman bra
you know kind of you know a darker man
and he wanted to do the tanning bed and
so I'm like you know I'm like you know I
you know you don't want to tell anybody
know that they shouldn't do the tanning
bed but this guy you know he's already
God kind of put him in the tanning bed a
little already so the Lord's got his you
know he's got that base and um cuz I
never seen a black guy get into a
tanning bed before so dude he would come
he would come and about the third or
fourth time he came I realized something
I'd have been wrong with him a little
bit but I don't know if something was
something also might have not have been
wrong with him he could have not been
wrong you know or nothing but but anyway
you do so the crazy this is so the wild
part is I used to get high back then
let's gonna smoking a lot of weed and
making exotic shakes for people somebody
roll in I'd hit him with that [ __ ]
peanut butter and menthol [ __ ] that
medium bro
there you go there like it's not cold
I'm like who gives a damn
they said it's called frozen options I
said well this is one of the options
baby okay one of the options is not cold
right and you got that you know I
[ __ ] hit somebody with that pineapple
walnut little baby shake you know I'm
gonna kind of do it I'll [ __ ] just
squeeze for cherries just just strangle
for cherries in the palm of my hand and
then just drip the just open my hand up
and then just drip it right into your
mouth you know I put two blueberries
under your tongue Brian how to [ __ ]
pecan and you ass bruh and slap your
cousin dog and that's a right there
that's 475 you know I'm the kind of guy
I'm serving up different options so
anyway do this stories a little bit
vulgar but you know talking about
urinating and having a you know handle
body and handle body you know things
that come out of your body in places but
anyway so one time the man went in there
and he had something that happened to
him and I heard him laughing in there
for a little bit or yelling or something
I'm not sure and dude I'm not the kind
of look if somebody's in a tanning bed
and they're doing going through some
[ __ ] I'm not that I'm I'm not opening
that [ __ ] shot okay it's a night during
their four nine minutes or 11 minutes I
think this dude and he was getting
blacker he was getting more Brooke you
know I mean he was definitely I don't
know if he was trying to get better at
sports I don't know why I still have no
idea why this man was trying to get
darkened out but he was [ __ ] you know
he was really he started out about like
a like a like I'm a Holmes and he
finished up like around a little bit of
like a kind of a kind of a kind of more
of a crisp ding Denzel
so that's really the range he was in you
know or but anyway so anyway he had a
bow bowel accident or a BM a grandma
least I call it you know when you
basically you have a boot you know you
you do throwing a little booty work out
of your
you know it's this is sorry this vulgar
to talk about but the man had a poop or
something in the what does that thing
called space-shuttle no it's a UH like a
hot like a little toaster [ __ ] I was
just talking about it tanning bed the
man had a little accident there well
dude I'll you know I'm working in the
shake shop Brian this was a startup so
you know maybe you got two employees so
the other employee was this chick dude
and she was bro this chick was addicted
attaining but anyway so anyway I had to
go guy had to clean the thing I had to
clean the I had to clean the the self
the tanning bed of the you know Cece but
fesses or whatever excrement but dude I
don't know anyway so I don't know if I
cleaned it that good or what happened
but anyway over about the next probably
three months dude probably about
probably about nine people got pinkeye
from the tanning bed at frozen options
and self tanning and um and damn dude
I've and then I would start seeing
people around town with pinkeye and I
would just feel bad bruh and I knew I do
I clean that thing so hard but I think
I'd you know you can only it's a it's
the dark arts man you know you can only
clean if somebody's been in a bunker in
a [ __ ] in that body bunker just
getting that tan on and you and they
blow up you know they throw some body
workout into the deal out of their
bottom you can't always no matter what
you clean it with I mean you know the
Lord Himself could hand you a mop and
you're not going to get it all up but uh
and then dude the place went under and
we sold the they sold the tanning bed so
I can't even imagine how many people got
got that itchy eye but you feel me
but hey things happen man things happen
sometimes so if you've ever had pinkeye
on Charleston I'm just singing man
that's one of the options dude that's
one of the options bro
because I worked in the smoothie place
dude I remember one time this lady came
in this lady was a damn Muppet and she
looked at the sign and all the different
fruits and different options and she
came up and she goes what's blueberries
and I [ __ ] lost my because this lady
the prob about 40 years old
what's blueberries and she just had
never heard of him so but then on the
same foot man on the other side of the
bunion or whatever they say I got to
also serve that lady the first servant
of blueberries she ever had you know
because that's what I do da I'm the kind
of guy bro you know I'm saying I put
[ __ ] five blueberries into an oyster
closed that [ __ ] up put it it put it in
your mouth from [ __ ] braid your hair
bruh and that's [ __ ] nine dollars
dawg that's a medial that's a medium
that's how I do it dude you know I'm
saying I'll take a hit off of a hot junk
blowing your cut blow it straight up
your cousin's fricken piehole bruh you
know that that that just just
shotgunning it right into his mouth you
know put a necktie on his ass
take him to [ __ ] up take him to uh you
know take them to our arm down by the
train tracks and [ __ ] tickle his ass
until the number six comes bro and
that's seven dollars dog that's a large
so that's the kind of that's that's who
you get that's what you get from me when
you get the different options and that's
the [ __ ] medium bruh oh you come in
you don't have any shoes on over a
frozen options dude oh well how about
this bruh
I'll throw up throw [ __ ] half a
grandma oat milk a couple two Winston's
in there dude - Winston Long's in there
1:12
you know I throw in a two scoops of
strawberry you know a little bit of
creme de cocoa bro that coconut crema
and I'll [ __ ] whip that [ __ ] up and
pour it right into your damn brassiere
and chill them tits off you feel me and
that's a large right there so I'm just
telling you how frozen options we got
different things you want pink eye from
the tanning bed we got it so shout out
to anybody in Charleston South Carolina
who has ever gotten pink eye to go with
that base bro if you got that that
healthy base tan you may also if you got
that itch bro you got a little bit of
downtime in you uptown you feel me and I
tried my best to clean that bed man but
we were understaffed over there
my god we were understaffed and it just
we were better than that damn I cleaned
that [ __ ] tanning bed brach clean
dude I can't even tell you how many
times because people come in Brian they
go tan in it one girls like imma stay in
there for about 19 minutes I was like
she definitely gonna get pinkeye she's
gonna get pinkeye on her dying buttocks
dude because that is that's too long in
there if you in there bacon and they
still got them body remnants from your
boy d'Artagnan bro
you know the 5th of fencer v um what is
that movie called the fifth musketeer oh
yeah I know dude hell you could probably
get a job right now at frozen options
baby you feel me come on in baby come on
in we got roller skates
we got tanning what's blueberries we got
them frozen options oh you have it Oh
what do you want that cowboy special huh
I'll take two hits of all I'll take two
dips of um of long cut throw it at in
the blender I'll take a I'll take up
half of a Pabst Blue Ribbon throw to
thing of um nutmeg in there and then
drop a [ __ ] copy of Reader's Digest
in that [ __ ]
you mix it up oh that's a medium for you
boy thank you guys for checking out this
clip and if you want to see another clip
and you can look at this clip or this
clip either one of these so did you pick
one or he's still just watching me do
this cuz this is alarming